[Music]  yeah and in blitz you know you don't  want to take won c-6 you prefer lights  over bishops that's I'm sure now he  takes because it was a blunder now in  King's Bishop e6 it's not that the rook  takes b7 is a possibility where white  wins that Yahoo 87 white wins a poll  like this it's an illegal move 93 it's  open what has happened a custom loss in  this case I'm not sure I'm not sure I  can give you no key have played in the  legal move cossutius after clock if he  plays another move that miss it silly go  you're lost really sailor Kiev won the  game like yes you mean yes I think  that's that's incredible oh my god  that's really incredible I mean that's  is this  [Music]  [Music]